Carla wrote in Carla said what's the
funniest computer use mistake you've
seen I've seen a lot of computer use
mistakes I don't want to say
specifically who did these things
because some of these people might
listen to the show but there's a lot of
just basic people who got into computers
later in life often make mistakes that
the US might seem kind of funny because
we grew up with a lot of this technology
but really there's nothing natural about
a double click versus a single click in
certain scenarios just sort of have to
learn it but some my favorite ones are
people triple clicking just in general
triple clicking on Windows buttons you
know it's like we have a single click in
the double click but the idea of the
triple click which like in word I
believe a triple click highlights the
entire paragraph or whatever but
generally speaking in Windows you don't
have too many applications for a triple
click double-clicking internet links is
also one that I've seen many many times
which is interesting you gotta make sure
I know one guy who would print and file
all emails in paper form at a friends
work even if you know how sometimes if
you're setting up a meeting you might go
hey I'd love to get together with you
what time works next week print response
Monday and Tuesday our best any
particular time that works for you
received print that respond 3 p.m.
monday would be great print ok I will
see you then print and a file for every
single one of these interactions we can
you imagine Lewis the environmental
impact of this alone aside from the
lunacy that's managing all these files
that's disgusting yeah and and I hate
that person and I'm hoping that they
really didn't get too many emails
because you would very quickly have a
this whole room which is fill up with
those papers I don't think it's anything
really to make fun of though right I
mean if you know I depending RB
depending no no I don't mean the
printing just in general these sort of
funny computer mistakes yeah if I were
right now told set up a typewriter
manually and set up the ribbon and
everything I'm sure I would make
mistakes that someone who grew up in the
time were typewriters were far more
common would say that's so silly how
could anyone make that mistake this is
the way things work and I'm sure there
will be technologies in years to come
where I will be asking you know my
little sister or some 10 year old to
help me figure out and it'll be sort of
the same thing if I didn't grow up with
it as a tool you're just not going to
have the same facility with it right and
after I've seen
many instances of uh countless of the
people who click yes to anything that
pops up although my you know there's a
million programs running they open up
their browser and at the actual window
of your browser is is is like this big
because of all the add-ons and when you
say this big you mean what uh it's like
an inch wide on your screen right much
the screen is just different toolbars
and plugins they have been installed
that's a very common thing but I I used
to be and you used to be right a
computer tutor right for a scene at a
Senior Center at a Senior Center so we
would teach the elderly how to use
computers is um I feel like that job was
very much responsible for me having to
think through the simplest way to
explain certain things yes it really it
was very helpful in that way and and it
has certainly taught me patience and how
to how to describe things plainly and be
concise but there is one instance where
I just started working with this woman
and I'm explaining how the computer
works how you interact with the computer
I said well you see this you see this
pointer here this is little arrow on the
screen that is your most important tool
that's what you use to to do almost
everything and wherever you move this
mouse that arrow will move and so she
took the mouse and she picked it up in
the air and started going like this
moving in immediately demanded some
circular motion in midair and uh idea it
was just very very funny yeah that that
is good that is a good one any others
you want to mention i'm i'm having
trouble remembering uh other other ones
from that from that era has a long time
ago but uh if there was just a lot of uh
a lot of book a total lack of
understanding of what is happening with
the computer conceptually ER
conceptually yes yes uh sometimes
insurmountable uh that was in late high
school and early college i was selling
computers at Circuit City the
now-defunct circuit city so there were a
lot of interesting stories from that and
I I do think that working at that
council on aging as they called it a
sort of Senior Center
and it's a good City and just having to
explain to people with drastically
different understandings of computers
how things work really helped develop
that skill I mentioned which is how what
is the way that I can communicate an
idea with language and in a sequence
that could be understandable to
essentially anyone and it's actually a
really good skill to have even in this
you know when we think about how to
communicate ideas on the show super
super useful no doubt yeah how many
people write books on that subject
matter yeah it's yeah great bonus show
coming up today david pakman.com slash
membership the website is brand-new we
have a brand new website which launched
about a week ago and it is extraordinary
and i invite you to visit it and check
it out today